oui
[Musique]
pendant et après les confinements liés
aux coronavirus de par le monde dès
qu'ils ont eu un tel impact sur nos vies
qui serait un meilleur invités que celui
que le new york times qualifié
d'intellectuel le plus influent du monde
occidental
le professeur jordan peterson auteur de
au delà de l'ordre me rejoint depuis
toronto au canada
jordan merci infiniment de revenir dans
notre émission je dois dire que vous
avez l'air d'être en forme je sais que
vous avez traversé une période difficile
c'est dans l'avant propos du livre vous
faites un podcast avec votre fils
michael a mais je suppose que je devrai
d'abord vous demander à quel point le
qu'ovide influencé l'écriture de votre
dernier ouvrage est bien j'étais isolé
comme tout le monde ça donne plus de
temps la situation a de toute évidence
eu un profond impact sur la
compréhension qu'à chacun de sa propre
fragilité et de sa propre mortalité
j'ai passé beaucoup de temps fermée avec
mes yeux par an
donc pour moi comme pour tout le monde
la pandémie a fait prendre conscience de
notre vulnérabilité de manière plus
aiguë in tout cela aussi je suppose
renforcer mon appréciation d'être
entouré de gens de ma famille mais je
suis certain que cette réaction ne met
pas propre ce livre au delà de l'ordre
si on le compare aux précédents se
focalise plus sur l'importance des
relations interpersonnelles
pour ce qui est de l'entretien de notre
santé comme contributeur à notre
compréhension que la vie vaut le coup
d'être vécue donc je pense sont d'autres
à cause du confinement liés aux qu'ovide
se livrer un peu plus réconfortant que
le précédent et je dois dire que je vous
ai récemment entendu dire qu'une
interview télévisée ne faisait pas
souvent justice non seulement à votre
travail mais à de nombreux travaux on
parle souvent de la nature de la
télévision et de son incapacité à
expliquer des idées complexes
j'ai vraiment remarqué la différence
entre un entretien avec des journalistes
télé de l'ancienne école et les nouveaux
analyste de podcasts et de chaînes
youtube qui ont l'habitude d'avoir le
temps et de laisser les choses aller là
où elles doivent aller et cela donne
aussi une certaine pérennité à
l'entretien tout cela est lié à la
technologie sont en très longtemps un
petit nombre d'entreprises tenait d'une
main de fer la technologie vidéo et bien
sûr ce n'était pas diffusée longtemps
donc les journalistes télé ne pouvait
bénéficier d'une vraie liberté car le
média en lui-même était un mode de
communication très cher la moindre
erreur pouvait avoir des conséquences
catastrophiques faire donc de manière
générale j'ai toujours trouvé que les
journalistes télé de l'ancienne école
donner plus l'impression d'être des
représentants de l'entreprise que des
êtres humains ayant une conversation
les nouveaux formats permettent cela et
j'espère que c'est pour le mieux je dois
vous poser une question sur je vais
directement allé à la règle numéro 8
parce que je pense que le manque de
beauté et d'esthétique qui a été
ressenti beaucoup plus intensément par
les gens lors du confinement du à cette
pandémie
c'est un mystère tout bio dit pourquoi
sommes nous aussi attirés par la beauté
pourquoi la beauté tels quelque chose
que nous apprécions ressentons
définissons et méditons son utilité
pratique immédiate n'est pas évidente
alors que sa valeur économique est
disproportionnée un magot à chaque fois
que je vais en europe
je suis marqué par la beauté d'une
architecture de la culture bien sûr
aussi mais restons-en l architecture
partout sur la planète
les gens font des pèlerinages en europe
essentiellement à cause de la beauté
spectaculaire de ces villes il ya
quelque chose dans la beauté qui nous
rappelle constamment et d'une manière
qui ne peut être
mon sujet à critique que la vie vaut la
peine d'être vécue
n'oubliez quelque chose dans l'harmonie
de la forme la noblesse du but
la créativité et l'audace qui parlent ce
qu'il ya de meilleur en nous il
encourage à se manifester mais qui ne
peut pas vivre sans ça il ya quelque
chose en nous qui nous pousse à toujours
aller plus loin à chercher quelque chose
de plus élevé depuis le noble la beauté
semble montrer le chemin parce qu'elle
n'est pas sujette à la critique
rationnelle les sources assez fiable de
sens intérieur
je pense que les gens font surtout cette
expérience avec la musique et qui est un
art qui je pense un effet
disproportionné sur notre culture
particulièrement parce qu'il est
difficile de trouver une signification
pratique à la musique la musique pendant
des décennies était l'élément culturel
premier pour la jeunesse une fois encore
les raisons ne sont pas bien clair
explique la musique ce sont les schémas
un entremêlement harmonieux de schémas
un assemblage couche par couche avec
l'ajout de la voix le monde lui-même
effet de schémas donc la musique est une
représentation du monde mais dans un
sens c'est une représentation du monde
comme il pourrait être ou comme il
devrait être
il ya quelque chose en nous qui a
absolument besoin de cela cela nous
renforce face à la fragilité de nos vies
et notre propre vulnérabilité
c'est intéressant que vous ayez choisi
le chapitre 8 parce que je dirais que
c'est le chapitre dont je suis le plus
satisfait de mes deux derniers livres
sur la méditation la de la beauté et sa
portée et sa crosse posthume je suppose
que j incite les gens qui pensent en
termes purement économique
en termes pratiques à voir que l'homme
ne vit pas que de pain
c'est une simple vérité
vous établissez une relation avec la
beauté même chez vous par exemple si
vous achetez une oeuvre d'art une
véritable oeuvre d'art qui vous parle
vous mettez chez vous quelque chose de
transcendant quelque chose qui dans un
sens est un portail vers le divin vous
introduisez cela dans votre vie et cela
peut vous transformer ce n'est pas
quelque chose à prendre à la légère
je suis sûr que des avocats en propriété
intellectuelle réagir et à l'impact
économique mais de toute évidence la
musique pour la jeunesse est bien
souvent synonyme de rebellions je vous
parle depuis le sud de londres où la
musique hip hop prospère vous parlez
dans votre livre de beethoven et vous
avez choisi de mentionner dans ce
dernier ouvrage des artistes comme blake
qui était connu pour ses sympathies
révolutionnaire world first bien sûr et
c'est écrit sur la révolution française
a d'ailleurs chez moi quelques oeuvres
d'art français révolutionnaire à quoi
david delacroix goya pollock qui était
membre du parti communiste
picasso qui a été membre du parti
communiste toute sa vie et a même refusé
de rendre sa carte du parti après avoir
entendu parler de ce qui se passait en
union soviétique
selon vous pourquoi tant d'artistes
écrivains musiciens irait contre vos
règle numéro 6 11 12 7 4 l'art la
musique est souvent l'oeuvre de
révolutionnaires qui ont des sympathies
pour le travail de karl marx
c'est bien je pense que dès qu'un
artiste soumet son art à la politique
il soumet le supérieur à l'inférieur
presque toujours une erreur on ne se
souvient pas de picasso parce qu'il
était communiste ses opinions politiques
ne sont pas plus intéressante que les
opinions politiques de n'importe qui
d'autre
il n'y avait rien à dire en tant que
communiste que n'aurait pas eu à dire
150 mille autres communistes mais il
avait bien quelque chose à dire en tant
qu'artiste or on constate dans notre
culture cet entremêlement de
l'expression politique et de
l'expression artistique
j'ai rarement vu un artiste qui ne se
retrouve pas en terrain glissant
dès qu'il sort de ce que l'on pourrait
appeler son domaine stellaire pour
descendre dans le monde de la politique
et je dirais aussi que si un artiste est
vraiment possédé par un esprit créatif
jane hupe il ne peut le formulées par
des mots les canucks pas de manière
explicite il ne peut en faire une
philosophie ou une idéologie car c'est à
l'heure de la propagande selon moi un
artiste est quelqu'un qui se trouve à la
pointe du développement de la pensée
leur propre pensée peut suivre tout cela
mais leurs pensées créatives relève de
l'avant garde
je pense que c'est pour cela qu'ils
peuvent avoir des affinités avec des
types de pensée politique que
révolutionnaire l'esprit créatif et en
lui même partie de l'éternel source de
renouveau et cette source de renouveau
est un élément révolutionnaire il est
facile de confondre cela avec la
politique révolutionnaire en tant que
tel mais l'art est infiniment plus
révolutionnaire que la révolution
politique il ne joue pas dans la même
catégorie tour - vous ne pensez pas que
guernica a une grande importance pour
ceux qui se font bombarder par des
avions soutenu par les britanniques au
yémen de nos jours on sait à quel point
pour des artistes comme beethoven ou
goya la révolution française a pu être
inspirante et dans ce livre vous citer
longuement williams lake sans doute l'un
des poètes britanniques les plus
révolutionnaires
il voulait la révolution je veux parler
de la chanson du texte jérusalem bien
sûr ch est bien garni cas par exemple
parle des horreurs de la guerre du chaos
et de l'horreur de la guerre aussi
quelque chose qu'on peut comprendre
peu importe l'origine de la guerre
disons je veux dire les conflits et les
guerres sont des constantes
existentielle d'accord guernica et
pourrions-nous dire une immortelle
oeuvres d'art
elle parle à tous ceux qui ont souffert
des conséquences de la guerre et les
raisons politiques qui a senti si
secondaire je ne suis pas sûr que
picasso aurait aimé que les troupes de
franco soient émus par guernica comme
non mais vous pouvez imaginer que
n'importe qui ayant eu un proche et les
oies news by disons blessés dans une
guerre dans une bataille dans un
bombardement pourrez regarder toutes les
angoisses que traduit ce tableau et il
verrait le reflet de ce qui se trame
dans son âme
peu importe votre regard politique la
guerre est une catastrophe
c'est une catastrophe pour ceux qui sont
impliqués je sais qu'on peut classer les
guerres en guerre justifiée et guerre
injustifiée et je sais bien qu'il y à
des tyrans et des révolutionnaires noble
mais l'art parle des fondamentaux de
l'expérience humaine
en dehors du monde politique et je pense
que c'est vrai peu importe les opinions
politiques déclarés de l'artiste je
pense vraiment psychologiquement que
nous faisons face à l'inconnu en usant
de diverses tactiques vous pouvez
exprimer ce que vous ressentez au sujet
de quelque chose que vous ne comprenez
pas grâce à la danse vous pouvez
demander et bien pourriez vous exprimer
ça en un message politique
ces danseurs pourrait peut-être le faire
mais ça ne veut pas dire que c'est ce
que signifie sa danse
si vous savez de quoi il retourne et que
vous pouvez traduire ça de manière
politique
vous n'avez pas à danser vous n'avez pas
à chanter ce sont des formes
d'exploration si vous voulez ce qui fait
écho au penseur marxiste gueorgui lukasz
qui préférait le conservateur balzac aux
révolutionnaires stendhal
je me dis que c'est un livre très
politique que vous avez écrit là je veux
dire vous dites que dostoïevski et
nietzsche avait prédit des catastrophes
en russie et en chine au sujet de ces
deux pays puisque nous parlons de guerre
on peut dire que la russie a sauvé le
monde du nazisme pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale et que la chine a sorti
plus de gens de la pauvreté que
n'importe quel autre pays dans
l'histoire de l'humanité 800 millions de
personnes
et durant la pandémie decaux vide on a
vu à quel point il avait été bien plus
efficaces que d'autres pays pour sauver
leurs populations du virus
la chine a sorti les gens de la pauvreté
mais à quel prix des castes je veux dire
les estimations quant au nombre de morts
durant le règne de mao
elles sont entre 60 et 100 millions la
chine n'a pas sorti les gens de la
pauvreté etc quand ils ont fait des
réformes raisonnable de marché la
plupart des progrès réalisés ont eu lieu
durant les deux trois dernières
décennies
donc je pense qu'on ne peut pas
justifier les excès du parti communiste
chinois en soulignant leur relativement
tardive succès bien sûr le rôle des
russes dans la victoire sur le nazisme
est indiscutable les russes ont souffert
d'horreur équivalente chez eux
particulièrement entre 1919 et 1959
ça a été un cataclysme ce qui s'est
passé en union soviétique a été un
cataclysme absolue alors que le reste du
monde
le monde occidental disons se sortait de
la pauvreté sans avoir à produire en
interne répression est mort en masse je
veux dire regardez la différence entre
la corée du sud et la corée du nord
c'est la meilleure preuve que vous
puissiez trouver la corée du nord n'est
même pas allumés la nuit ils ne
produisent même pas d'électricité
tout le monde a faim pour être tout à
fait juste 20 % de la population de
corée du nord a été exterminée par les
états unis et l'angleterre pendant la
guerre professeur jordan peterson nous
reprendrons notre entretien après cette
courte pause
[Musique]
je suis toujours avec le professeur
jordan peterson et auteur de au delà de
l'ordre tous nouvelles règles pour une
vie dans ce livre la lutte des classes
est considéré comme une voix trompeuses
pour bien mener sa vie
vous dites que les inégalités sont
immuables selon la loi de pareto
peu importe le type d'armes employées le
type de grève que mènent les syndicats
on ne peut altérer les inégalités dans
la distribution des richesses
vous pouvez certainement l'altérer en
estimant que les inégalités dans la
distribution sont une conséquence
secondaire du capitalisme
ce n'est pas comme si je prenais le
problème des inégalités à la légère
je prends cela bien plus au sérieux que
les penseurs marxistes parce qu'il
attribue au capitalisme ce qui est
parfaitement ridicule c'est tellement
simpliste et arriérée et le pire étant
que cela dessert terriblement les
pauvres nous faisons face à deux
problèmes économiques au sens large du
terme
l'un est le problème de la privation
absolue il serait mieux que tout le
monde est assez à manger et c'est
quelque chose qu'on pourrait peut-être
mesurer avec une moyenne approximative
mais ensuite vous avez la question de la
distribution à la moyenne et la question
de la pauvreté relative qui est aussi un
problème est ce que je pense que les
penseurs politiques de gauche envisagent
de la bonne manière la question de la
pauvreté relative
ils sont utiles c'est utile je n'ai
jamais dit que la gauche n'avait pas un
important rôle à jouer dans le débat
politique en particulier pour ce qui est
de donner une voix crédible à la classe
ouvrière info reste de working class et
stx ce sont les excès les excès
idéologique des utopistes de gauche
contre lesquels je me dresse le danger
se trouve dans l'incapacité de la gauche
modérée à tracer une ligne entre d'une
part ce qui est acceptable disons en
relation avec le socialisme démocratique
et le syndicalisme ces choses qui ont
apporté de grands bénéfices notamment
canada et l'utopie excessif des radicaux
de gauche d'autre part ça va juger
vous en avez débattu avec slavoj zizek
mais marx adoré le capitalisme le
manifeste du parti communiste est une
ode au capitalisme je ne suis pas sûr
qu'ils ignoraient la grande avancée
qu'elle ait opéré le capitalisme si vous
mettez vos habits de psychanalyste est
ce que ce n'est pas un peu inspirant on
s'est souvent demandé d'où venaient
toutes ces choses concernant la société
du futur
ce n'est pas dans l'oeuvre de marx mais
cela nous montrer comment on devait
progresser en tant que société comment
on est passé de la féodalité au
capitalisme
peut-on considérer que c'est inspirant
il y a quelque chose d'inspirant mais il
ya aussi un aspect qui pousse à la
révolution violente sanglante et on en a
vu les conséquences
vous savez durant ce débat avec ace de
la poésie zec j'en prendrai les 15
premières minutes qui en sont une
critique du manifeste du parti
communiste
certains me critiquer pour ne pas me
concentrer sur les travaux plus
importants de marx mais étant donné que
c'est le pamphlet qui a mis le monde
sens dessus dessous
j'ai considéré que c'était une bonne
manière de commencer alors que j'étais
en train de faire ma critique que je
soulignais que c'était un appel à la
révolution violente là de nombreuses
personnes dans le public se sont mis à
applaudir ce qui m'a surpris je suis
resté silencieux 15 secondes
parce que je me suis dit hé bien vous
dévoilez votre vrai visage
est ce que vous êtes vraiment pour les
pauvres ou est ce que vous attendez
juste une violente révolution
on peut penser qu'on ne serait pas en
mesure de se parler tous les deux sens
les sanglante révolution du passé
je posais la question de la pertinence
de tout ça par rapport à ce livre parce
que certains voient souvent ça comme une
théorie marxiste de la libération
alors que l'église catholique avec les
armes domine en amérique latine
vous parlez de l'importance des leçons
du christ et l'importance de la
conscience et vous dites qu'il faut
toujours se battre pour sa conscience et
che guevara parler de ce genre de choses
dans ses journaux
je le prendrais personnellement pas
comme un exemple particulièrement
positif
et le moins qu'on puisse dire je
m'intéresse plus dans ce livre à la
relation qu'entretiennent les gens avec
leur conscience
j'ai été critiqué pour ignorer les
inégalités sociales
mais je n'ai jamais demandé à qui que ce
soit dans mes écrits ou dans mes
conférences est d'ignorer les causes
sociétales plus large
je demande juste aux gens de prendre le
contrôle de ce qu'ils peuvent contrôler
et prendre la responsabilité de leur
propre éthique personnelle je parle de
la conscience dans le livre parce que
c'est assez mystérieux c'est un mystère
qui montre que nous ne sommes pas
maîtres de nous mêmes c'est quelque
chose qui m'a beaucoup marqué en tant
que psychologue et penseur nietzsche
considérer que les fondations de notre
système judéo chrétien ayant été
détruite avec la mort de dieu nous
aurions à créer notre propre système de
valeurs le problème ici c'est que ça ne
semble pas tenable parce que nous avons
affaire à des forces en nous que nous ne
contrôlons pas donc si vous créez votre
propre système de valeurs il vous faut
vous demander pourquoi vous seriez
tourmenté par votre conscience et votre
conscience vous parle et approche
quelque chose qui ressemble à la voie
d'une mortalité transcendantale ce n'est
pas aussi direct parce que ce n'est pas
mission mais ça reste une voie à
laquelle on ne peut pas échapper des
parallèles ont été établis par des
penseurs religieux entre la voix de la
conscience et la voix de dieu ou
l'esprit du christ selon la tradition
judéo-chrétienne on intériorise des
idéaux qui nous jugent en dépit de
toutes nos bonnes intentions
il ya là dedans quelque chose de très
réel très puissant inéluctable est très
utile sau et donc c'est un mystère
la conscience est un mystère et je ne
crois pas qu'il y ait dans la vie
quelque chose de plus important que
notre relation à notre conscience
les critiques qui peuvent dire que vous
êtes l'intellectuel idéal pour les
puissantes élites qui cherche à
promouvoir leurs idées étant donné que
vous n'appelez pas la révolution mais
avec ce que vous venez de dire pensez
vous que quelqu'un qui liraient ce livre
et je pense qu'il va se vendre pour être
inspiré par ce que vous dites sur la
conscience mais c'est finalement assez
politique
je ne pense pas qu'il y ait d'actes plus
révolutionnaire que de dire la vérité
mes livres soutiennent l'élite je ne
pense pas que ce soit vrai une seule
seconde à moins que l'élite ne soit un
certain degré ce plu par la vérité je
demande aux gens de prêter attention
enfin je ne demande pas je dis qu'il est
important de prêter attention vous êtes
en faveur de changements progressifs
plutôt que d'une révolution et affirmé
que le tempérament politique relève de
la biologie ce type d'idées convient aux
élites car elles ne veulent pas que les
gens deviennent trop violent je voudrais
vous demander une chose qui est lié à
tout ça en un sens qu'est ce que le
codex de bèze que vous mentionnez dans
votre livre et qui semble mettre en
lumière cette tension entre
conservatisme et révolution c'est un
texte religieux apocryphe qui contient
quelque chose de particulièrement
intéressant quant à l'utilité
d'outrepasser les règles elles se
souviennent
il ya une histoire particulière dans ce
texte si je me souviens bien c'est au
sujet du christ et d'un mouton commencé
dans un puits le jour du shabbat
il observe quelqu'un qui essaie de
sauver le mouton coincé dans un puits au
soleil le jour du shabbat
alors le christ lui dit si tu sais ce
que tu es en train de faire
tu es béni
tu ne sais pas tu ne fais que
transgressé la loi et tu es maudit cette
phrase m'a particulièrement frappé parce
que c'est un point de vue extrêmement
sophistiqués sur la moralité les lois
l'idée est qu'il y ait une raison pour
l'existence du shabbat n'est ce pas il
faut que cela reste sacrée disons que
tout le monde a besoin d'une pause une
fois par semaine pour que la société
reste stable et que les gens restent en
bonne santé
j'ai peut-être qu'il ya des situations
où une interdiction de travailler ce
jour là peut être suspendue donc si le
berger à 10 ont de l'empathie ressent la
souffrance de son mouton il comprend
l'utilité de la règle du shabbat qui la
tient comme les autres de sa culture
pour sacrer mais qu'il décide qu'un
principe supérieur lui demande cet
effort particulier il transcende la loi
ait agi en tant qu'agents morale
supérieure qu'il est béni dans ce cas ci
c'est juste de la négligence d'une règle
sociale par narcissisme ou égoïsme il
sera maudit c'est pourquoi je mentionne
cette histoire on voit cette tension
permanence dans la littérature et vous
mentionner aussi pinocchio dans ce livre
rapidement un conseil pratique
que devons-nous faire que nos dirigeants
nous mentent je sais que vous étiez à
moscou quand edward snowdon a fui les
états unis après ses révélations sur la
surveillance de masse à julian assange
est ici à londres
il a été torturé selon l'onu par les
autorités britanniques lui aussi pour
avoir révélé des choses sur nos
dirigeants
que devrions nous faire quand on pense
que nos dirigeants nous mentent il est
difficile de dire ce que chaque personne
devrait faire au niveau individuel parce
que cela dépend grandement des
particularités de sa vie je ne pense pas
que les gens devraient faire fi des
affaires politiques
mais je pense que si vous voulez entrer
dans le monde politique
vous devriez faire en sorte que votre
psyché soit stable donc si vous voulez
entrer dans le monde politique
vous voulez faire en sorte d'être
quelqu'un qui est capable d'user du
pouvoir avec sagesse a plutôt que d'en
user de la manière de nos dirigeants
actuels que vous décriez ce n'est pas
simple et vous n'y arriverez pas en
adoptant pour la forme
une idéologie partagé par des millions
d'autres gens mais dans laquelle vous ne
vous retrouverez pas est votre idée
disons que tous les problèmes de
l'humanité peuvent être attribués à
l'élite actuelle la classe dirigeante ou
quelque chose comme ça n'aide en rien ça
ne sert à rien ce n'est pas du tout
assez sophistiqué pour régler le moindre
problème
il vous faut vous demander ces gens qui
sont devenus des tyrans quand on leur a
donné le pouvoir qu'est ce qui les rend
vraiment différent de moi
vous dites que ce n'est pas une question
d'opinion que la politique se fonde sur
un tempérament ine il ya 50 millions
d'individus à l'heure actuelle qui
dépendent de l'aide alimentaire aux
états unis et dont je vous parle il ya
des banques alimentaires au coin de la
rue et il ya la catastrophe
environnementale
vous ne croyez pas en la lutte des
classes mais on ne voyez vous pas
comment tout cela peut bénéficier à ceux
qui sont au sommet je ne crois pas que
les inégalités soient générés par le
capitalisme
de toute évidence il y a
fondamentalement du stress et des
tensions dans tous les systèmes
on pourrait se trouver dans un système
féodal août dans un système soviétique
communiste
yuuwaa vous dit qu'il ne faut pas isoler
une chose en particulier
en fait vous dit faites attention aux
intellectuels qui fonde leur intention
un monothéisme
on peut imaginer que vous parlez de
monothéisme dans votre livre et que
c'est l'effet que ça sur nous les
lecteurs
et je ne fais pas ça politiquement voilà
la différence
est-ce que tout n'est pas politique je
ne pense pas non pas du tout je pense
que la politique à sa place mais non il
ya plein d'autres choses
c'est cela qui est intéressant dans
notre culture les gens mettent cette
idée en avant comme si c'était une
vérité
mais non pourquoi tout devrait être
politique tout n'est pas économique
non mais qu mais la vivarié la beauté
n'est pas politique pourrait les camps
mis la musique n'est pas politique
l'amour n'est pas politique l'art n'est
pas politique
l'écran est bien terminons cet entretien
/ sur l'amour alors professeur peterson
merci c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
[Musique]
m